de rougier est avec nous bonjour vous
êtes notre consultant sur les questions
militaires le bombardement de ni
prophète il craindre que cette offensive
russe est en train de s'étendre oui on a
encore du mal à expliquer pourquoi
est-ce que c'est maintenant et ici mais
ce qui est clair c'est comme vous l'avez
rappelé nous sommes face à une ville d'à
peu près un million d'habitants qui est
au bord du dniepr et qui est à la fois
au sud de kharkiv est donc d'une ville
qui est là depuis longtemps et qui est
également au nord est de nicolay f qui
est le dernier verrou avant odessa donc
il ya sans doute la volonté à ce bain
dans cette danse est premier ses
premières frappes aériennes de marquer
le territoire entre guillemets et de
préparer sans doute une jonction de
plusieurs offensives celles venant de
l'est du nord-est et potentiellement
donc du sud sachons pour nikolaïev
l'idée est bien de remonter en suivant
le nord-ouest et de 2,2 en quelque sorte
de prendre en écharpe odessa qui sinon
seraient
ouverte à la marina la marine russe